Aujourd'hui, on va parler d'amour.
Vous connaissez forcément
ce bon vieux débat.
Est-ce que les opposés s'attirent?
Ou est-ce que ce qui se
ressemble s'assemble?
Verdict juste après le Loïc générique !
Donc, d'après la science, qui se ressemble
s'assemble, le débat est terminé.
On peut arrêter la vidéo là.
Mais ça peut expliquer.
Oui, mais pourquoi?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans le cerveau?
Ça vaut vraiment le coup
de creuser le sujet.
Il y a des sc...
Il y a des scientifiques qui ont étudié
la question et qui ont affirmé
que les personnes qui se ressemblent
physiquement s'assemblent.
Et je suis certain que vous avez déjà
croisé ce genre de couples dans la rue
qui ont une ressemblance tellement
troublante qu'un moment donné,
on se demande s'ils sont pas
frères et sœurs entre eux.
Vous trouvez pas ça fou, en vrai?
Genre eux....
Et là, je suis sûr que vous
êtes en train de réfléchir,
si, dans votre entourage,
vous en connaissez,
peut-être que vous-même vous êtes en train
de vous dire : "ah ouais, en fait,
je ressemble un petit peu à ma moitié.
C'est vrai maintenant qu'il le dit".
Mais est-ce qu'on pourrait pas se dire
que le fait qu'il y ait des couples qui se ressemblent,
c'est comme si une partie
d'eux-mêmes réussissait à hacker l'ADN
de l'autre pour en dupliquer
les spécificités.
Et c'est là où je me dis "il faudrait
presque un VPN pour les protéger de ça !"
Et justement, ça tombe bien,
vous avez vu que la vidéo d'aujourd'hui
est sponsorisée par NordVPN.
NordVPN c'est quoi?
Vous savez ce que c'est,
mais je vais le redire... C'est LE VPN.
Élu meilleur des VPN, lors des "Best
VPN Awards" 2019 et 2020.
Parce que oui, il y a des concours
de VPN faits par vpnMentor et PC mag.
L'utilisation de NordVPN,
c'est super simple, c'est pour toutes
les applications que vous ayez déjà
utilisé un VPN ou non,
leurs serveurs sont extrêmement rapides
et vous pouvez avoir jusqu'à 6
appareils connectés sur un même compte.
Vous pouvez même l'utiliser en double VPN
si vous voulez chiffrer le chiffrage.
Mais du coup, ça sert à quoi NordVPN ?
Ça vous sert
à surfer avec plus de sécurité quand vous
êtes sur des Wi-Fi publics,
par exemple dans un bar, dans un train,
en voyage, à l'hôtel,
dans une bibliothèque...
Mais aussi, à contourner les géo-restrictions
pour regarder depuis chez vous
des programmes étrangers, ou des programmes
français quand vous, vous êtes à l'étranger.
Bref, c'est utile.
Si un VPN vous intéresse,
il vous faut NordVPN.
Et pourquoi?
Parce que vous avez la garantie
30 jours satisfait ou remboursé.
Parce que le service client de NordVPN
est dispo 24h sur 24, 7 jours sur 7.
Et surtout,
parce qu'avec l'offre "Christmas Deal",
si vous passez par mon lien qui est en
description avec le code : "Fabien Olicard" ...
Vous avez tout ici.
Vous recevrez quatre mois gratuits
pour un abonnement de deux ans.
Et ça, ça fait plaisir.
Merci NordVPN !
En 1987, il y a un psychologue de l'Université
du Michigan qui s'appelle Robert Zajonc.
Il a réalisé une étude selon
laquelle les couples mariés pendant 25 ans
se ressemblent de plus en plus
physiquement au fil du temps.
Pourquoi?
Ben, c'est vraiment ce qu'il s'est dit : pourquoi?
Il a donc mené une expérimentation qui est
basée sur 12 photos de couples
au moment de leur mariage.
Une photo de ce même couple,
mais 25 ans après.
Et Robert précise que tous les couples
étaient blancs, vivaient dans le Michigan
ou dans le Wisconsin et qu'ils avaient
entre 50 et 60 ans au moment
de la deuxième photo.
Donc, 25 ans après, la conclusion
de ce cher Robert est sans équivoque.
Les couples se ressemblent.
Du moins, se ressembleraient au fil du temps
en raison d'un mode de vie commun,
d'une alimentation plutôt similaire
et surtout, des émotions partagées.
C'est à dire que au fur et à mesure
de leur vie commune,
ils vivent les mêmes choses en même temps,
ce qui génère les mêmes émotions,
donc les mêmes choses sur leur visage,
donc les mêmes rides aux mêmes endroits.
Tout cela, au final,
serait susceptible de façonner
le visage des deux personnes du couple.
Ça aurait une incidence sur le contour
du visage et donc sur certains types
de rides, comme si on imitait
les expressions faciales de son conjoint.
Et on aurait aussi tendance à adopter
le même langage corporel,
la même gestuelle, les mêmes intonations
que la personne avec qui on partage sa vie.
D'après cette étude aussi,
plus le couple est heureux,
plus les amoureux seraient susceptibles
de se ressembler physiquement
au fil du temps.
Robert a ajouté : vous souriez tous les deux
parce que vous vous sentez bien et vous
vous sentez bien, parce que vous souriez tous les deux.
Pourquoi?
Pourquoi ça t'arrange pas?
Tu as peur de te tasser.
Non mais ça, je comprends.
Mais en fait, ça ne
marche que sur les couples amoureux.
Cette théorie, elle a été approuvée
par le psychologue suédois Olaf Dimberg,
qui a mené une petite expérimentation
sur quelques volontaires.
L'essai était très simple :
mesurer les niveaux de tension dans les muscles
du visage des volontaires,
auxquels on a montré
des photos de visages exprimant
une émotion en particulier :
colère, tristesse, etc.
La plupart des volontaires agissaient
par mimétisme lorsqu'ils voyaient
un visage en colère,
leurs muscles de leurs visages copiaient
cette expression et exprimaient de la colère
à un faible degré.
À l'œil nu, c'était quasiment pas visible,
mais les machines ont pu détecter cette micro-expression.
Donc c'est
un mimétisme naturel qu'on a.
C'est ce qui permet aussi au cerveau
de comprendre les émotions de l'autre que
de reproduire un petit peu ses muscles faciaux.
Le mimétisme, c'est un signe d'empathie
qui déclenche des substances chimiques
à l'intérieur du cerveau, comme si la
personne vivait l'émotion de l'autre.
Pour mieux comprendre
ce que l'autre ressent.
Selon Robert, les couples partagent
tellement d'expressions et d'émotions
similaires au cours des événements heureux
et malheureux qu'ils traversent dans leur vie,
qu'ils ont tendance à se ressembler.
Lors d'une émotion les muscles qu'on a sur
le visage se tendent ou se détendent.
Il estime que cela est susceptible
de resserrer les artères,
les veines du visage et donc d'augmenter
le flux sanguin à certains endroits.
Ce flux sanguin va déclencher
des substances chimiques dans le cerveau ;
substances étant responsables de certaines
émotions, et les changements
seraient donc aussi à l'intérieur.
En d'autres termes, quand vous voyez votre
partenaire qui sourit,
vous souriant en retour,
ce sourire produit une contraction
des muscles de votre visage
qui appuient sur les veines.
Le flux sanguin sera alors modifié jusqu'à
déclencher un état émotionnel
semblable à celui de votre conjoint.
Si notre cher Robert,
(je ne sais pas pourquoi je dis "cher
Robert"... j'ai envie..) est déjà ultra convaincu,
il y a d'autres scientifiques qui sont
restés très sceptiques face à sa
publication et ... à ma capacité d'articuler...
Paul Ekman, par exemple,
psychologue à l'Université de San Francisco,
que vous connaissez très
bien sur la chaîne, parce qu'on a parlé
de lui environ mille fois ou mille deux
cent fois sur la chaîne, a déclaré :
les expériences de la vie courante au fil
des ans peuvent modifier la musculature
faciale et les rides, ce qui entraîne
une plus grande ressemblance.
Mais il n'y a aucune raison de croire
que cela ait un rapport avec
le flux sanguin vers le cerveau.
D'autres psychologues ont aussi fortement
contesté la théorie de Robert,
jusqu'à ce que l'un d'entre eux,
Allen Friedland,
un psychologue de l'Université de Pennsylvanie,
a écrit une critique
très détaillée de cette théorie.
Pennsylvanie
Donc, Robert,
il s'en prend plein la tête.
Tout le monde s'en prend à lui.
Mais Pin Pin Tea-Makorn et Michal Kosinski ...
Mais moi, ça me fatigue ... les noms des chercheurs, je te jure.
Les psychologues, les chercheurs.
Il y a rarement
un Jean-François .... Jean-François Durand.
Il n'empêche que ces deux chercheurs
de l'Université de Stanford,
aux Etats-Unis,
se sont penchés sur l'étude de Robert
et ont réfuté aussi la théorie selon
laquelle les couples se
ressemblent au fil du temps.
Mais faut savoir que l'étude qui avait été
réalisée par Robert a été faite
sur un échantillon qui est très
faible : seulement 12 couples !
Donc, il y a rien de très probant,
en effet ... scientifiquement parlant.
L'échantillon est trop faible.
Donc, les chercheurs de Stanford sont
plutôt partisans du fait que les couples
se choisissent en fonction des similitudes physiques.
Et ça, dès le début de la relation.
Pour eux, inconsciemment,
on aurait tendance a être attiré
par quelqu'un qui a les mêmes
traits physiques que nous.
Comme si on était à la recherche
d'un visage familier,
de quelqu'un qu'on connaît.
Et ils ont mené une petite expérimentation
grâce à la technologie moderne.
Ils ont publié leurs résultats en octobre 2020,
donc c'est très,
très récent et c'est très intéressant.
Petit aparté, il faut savoir que ces chercheurs vont aussi
étudier la question : est-ce qu'il est
possible de deviner le nom d'une personne
simplement en examinant son visage?
Du coup, ça tombe bien,
je m'étais servi de cette étude pour faire
une vidéo sur le sujet et je vous
la partagerai à la fin de la vidéo.
C'était sur "l'effet Dorian Gray".
Bref, ils ont parcouru des tas et des tas
de journaux de sites internet
à la recherche d'avis d'anniversaires
de mariage et ils ont réussi à constituer
une base de données de photos de 517
couples, prises dans les deux ans suivant
le mariage et entre 20
et 69 ans plus tard.
A noter que tous les couples sélectionnés
étaient blancs et hétérosexuels.
Les chercheurs n'avaient pas pu recueillir
assez d'images de couples homosexuels ou
mixtes pour en faire une base de données.
Voici ce que les chercheurs
ont mis en place.
Ils ont créé 2068 combinaisons
qui ressemblaient à la chose suivante :
en haut, l'une des deux
personnes d'un couple.
En bas, plusieurs visages mélangés
qui incluaient l'autre personne du couple,
soit dans les deux ans de leur relation,
soit des années après.
La tâche de chacun des participants était
de classer les visages du dessous
en allant du plus ressemblant, au moins
ressemblant du visage cible dessus.
Pour 2068 combinaisons.
À savoir évidemment que dans les 2068 combinaisons,
à un moment donné,
ce visage cible du dessus allait revenir,
avec le visage de l'autre
moitié de ce même couple,
mais, à une période beaucoup plus lointaine du couple.
Ce que les chercheurs
essayaient de savoir était bien :
est-ce que les deux personnes du même
couple se ressemblaient plus
au moment de leur rencontre
ou plus des années après leur rencontre,
quand ils ont beaucoup vécu ensemble?
Le plus intéressant,
c'est que ce travail a été aussi effectué
ensuite par un algorithme avec
les mêmes critères pour le même but.
Les chercheurs en ont conclu
que les couples ne se ressemblent pas plus
avec le temps, mais bel et bien
dès le début de la relation.
En gros, on se dirige naturellement
vers des gens qui ont la même tête
que nous, de la même façon qu'on recherche
souvent des personnes qui ont les mêmes
valeurs ou les mêmes intérêts que nous.
Du coup Loïc, tu comprends
bien le titre de ma vidéo :
"L'amour se trouve peut-
être devant le miroir".
Sauf si j'ai décidé de prendre
un autre type de vidéo.
Lucy Vincent,
une docteure en neurosciences,
a dit d'ailleurs que si on nous demandait
de décrire le partenaire de nos rêves,
on ne dirait jamais qu'on voudrait
quelqu'un qui se rapproche
le plus possible de nous-mêmes.
Et pourtant,
selon les données sociologiques,
c'est bien lui qu'on recherche
et qu'on trouve parfois.
Lucy Vincent ça allait...
J'avais un côté Francky Vincent....
association d'idées....
Elle dit aussi que ce
phénomène est universel.
Dans tous les pays du monde où l'on a
procédé au relevé des données,
on a observé que les couples se
ressemblent bien plus que deux
personnes prises au hasard dans la rue.
C'est vrai aux États-Unis.
C'est vrai aussi en Angleterre,
en Corée, en Suède, même au Canada.
Au delà de vouloir rechercher des traits
familiers, c'est selon elle une peur
de l'inconnu qui nous fait faire ça.
Parce qu'on accorde plus facilement notre confiance
à quelqu'un qui nous ressemble
physiquement et dans lequel on
se reconnaît un peu en mode :
"on fait partie de la même tribu" !
D'ailleurs, d'autres chercheurs s'étaient
déjà penchés sur la question
de la ressemblance physique.
C'était en 2012, en France,
à l'université de Montpellier,
il y avait des volontaires masculins
qui avaient participé au test suivant :
choisir le visage féminin le plus séduisant
parmi des photos
qui leur étaient montrées.
Il faut savoir que parmi ces photos se trouvaient
des visages féminins qui avaient été créés
artificiellement,
avec des traits similaires aux volontaires
qui participaient à l'expérience.
Résultat, la plupart des volontaires
avaient sélectionné le visage de la femme
créé artificiellement avec
des traits semblables aux leurs.
En gros, Loïc, ta femme idéale,
elle ressemble à ça :
.... Ça fait pas rêver non plus ...
Dans ce même registre,
un autre phénomène est intéressant
à étudier : il s'agit de l'homogamie.
Alors l'homogamie,
c'est un phénomène qui est
déjà observé chez les animaux.
En gros, les oiseaux,
les mammifères ou encore les poissons sont
attirés par des partenaires qui sont
semblables à leurs géniteurs.
C'est comme si une maman chèvre s'occupait
d'un bébé mouton et que ce bébé mouton,
une fois grand, choisirait de s'accoupler
avec une partenaire chèvre.
On appelle ça aussi
l'empreinte sexuelle positive.
Bref, chez nous, chez les humains,
ça fait que certaines personnes auraient
tendance à aller vers des partenaires
qui leur seront proches génétiquement.
On peut donc être attiré par des personnes
qui ressemblent à nos parents,
notre père ou notre mère.
Dit comme ça, c'est un peu chelou.
Mais en fait, ça n'a rien à voir
avec le complexe d'Œdipe.
Là, ce coup-ci. Tu connais le complexe d'Œdipe?
Mais là, s'il faut être bilingue....
Donc non. Rien à voir
avec le complexe d'Œdipe.
C'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas d'attirance sexuelle
refoulée pour l'un des deux parents.
Ce n'est pas ça le délire.
Il y a une enquête très intéressante
qui a été réalisée à ce sujet.
C'était en 2004.
Des chercheurs qui ont fait une étude
sur des enfants adoptés et il s'avère
qu'il y a un lien entre le mari
des filles adoptées et le père adoptif.
Mais encore une fois,
pas un truc de sexualité refoulée.
Encore plus troublant,
plus la qualité de la relation avec
le père adoptif était bonne,
plus le futur marié a des chances
de ressembler à son beau père.
Les filles qui recevaient plus de support
émotionnel de la part de leur père adoptif
avaient plus de chances de choisir
un partenaire similaire que celles
qui avaient une relation moins
positive avec leur père.
C'est vrai, t'as raison de le dire.
Bravo
mais tu n'y avais pas pensé seul...
Sache que les chercheurs...
Sache que les chercheurs aussi se sont
posés la question, ils se sont dit :
"mais, il n'y a pas que le physique dans la vie".
Il y a quelqu'un qui a
dit : "c'est vrai" et ils ont fait ..." Ouais,
je sais que c'est vrai" .... Une histoire sans fin.
Les scientifiques sont plutôt d'accord.
L'attirance est plus probable
entre des personnes qui ont des points
communs plutôt qu'entre des personnes
qui ont des différences radicales.
Déjà, c'est le cas professionnellement,
parce qu'on se dirige instinctivement
vers des personnes qui sont
de la même classe sociale que nous.
L'étude, qui a été réalisée entre 69
et 2011 par Milan Boucher-Valat
sur des couples hétérosexuels,
déclare que huit pour cent des ouvriers
vivent avec une ouvrière ou une employée,
contre trois pour cent avec
une femme cadre supérieur.
Côté centres d'intérêt,
c'est exactement la même chose et on en a
déjà tous fait l'expérience dans notre
quotidien, que ce soit
en amitié ou en amour.
Si vous êtes passionné d'escalade
et que vous rencontrez une personne
qui est passionnée d'escalade, ben
ça fait un feeling quoi, ça
matche un peu directement.
On appréciera plus cette personne parce
que elle aime les mêmes choses que nous ou qu'on
peut avoir des discussions sur ce sujet.
C'est ce qui a été confirmé par des
chercheurs de l'Université de Wellesley.
Il y a trop de chercheurs
dans cette vidéo !
Ils ont découvert un lien entre la durée
d'une relation et le fait de partager
les mêmes valeurs,
aspirations et centres d'intérêt.
Si certains diraient que la différence
fait la richesse de l'autre,
on peut aussi admettre qu'une personne
qui nous ressemble a suffisamment
de différences pour nous compléter.
Alors, d'après vous,
vous pensez plutôt que la clé du bonheur
amoureux, ça serait d'être avec quelqu'un
qui nous ressemble ou d'être
avec un total opposé?
Loïc
toi ... ressemble ? OK.
Dites-moi dans les commentaires ce que vous pensez.
En vrai, je
serais curieux d'avoir votre avis.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu.
N'oubliez pas de likez cette vidéo.
Je m'appelle toujours Fabian Olicard.
Abonnez-vous à cette chaîne YouTube!
Activez la cloche.
Les deux, c'est gratuit,
mais c'est important.
Partagez vos photos de couple....
OK, je reformule.
Si ça vous chauffe,
vous mettez une photo où il y a
vous et votre moitié sur Instagram.
vous tapez mon
Instagram pour me taguer dedans.
Vous me taguer, comme ça,
ça va apparaître dans mes stories,
et comme ça, j'en partagerai pas mal
dans mes stories et je mettrai
des sondages pour voir si les gens
trouvent que vous vous ressemblez ou pas.
Tu vois à peu près les....
... en me tapant ...
Et je n'oublie pas également de remercier
NordVPN qui a sponsorisé cette vidéo.
Vous pouvez télécharger NordVPN en passant
par mon lien dans la description et vous profiterez
du "Christmas Deal" qui vous
offre 4 mois pour un abonnement de deux ans
en utilisant donc mon lien
et mon code Fabien Olicard.
Bon hé bien, si vous voulez continuer sur un
autre video, là, je vous mets une vidéo.
J'ai passé le test d'aptitude
des agents secrets.
Est-ce que j'y suis parvenu?
Je vous laisse regarder et là,
je vous mets une autre vidéo ...
.. bien.. Je sais pas encore tiens ! Ah si, c'est celle-ci.
Un casse-tête 3000 euros, quand même...
c'est pas .. donné, donné, quand même.
Ah oui,
et puis, Loïc et moi,
nous voulons nous associer pour vous
souhaiter une bonne année.
C'est dans 2 jours, la bonne année ....
bonne année !!